WELCOME BACK.
MY NEXT GUEST HAS APPEARED ON
"INSIDE AMY SCHUMER" AND HAD HIS
OWN COMEDY CENTRAL SPECIAL.
PLEASE WELCOME MARK NORMAND!
( APPLAUSE )
♪ ♪ ♪
( LAUGHTER )
HEY, HEY.
HOW YOU GUYS FEELING?
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
ALL RIGHT.
GOOD TO BE HERE.
YOU'RE DOING BETTER THAN ME.
I'M A LITTLE HUNG OVER.
YEAH.
ISN'T THAT AMAZING, WE STILL
CAN'T PREVENT A HANG OVER.
WE HAVE ALL THIS MEDICAL
RESEARCH.
I'VE TRIED THE WATER.
I'VE TRIED THE PILLS.
NOTHING WORKS.
WE CAN CAN PREVENT CHILDREN.
( LAUGHTER )
CAN'T PREVENT A HANGOVER.
AT LEAST SOME PEOPLE WANT KIDS.
I'VE NEVER WOKEN UP LIKE, "WHOA.
I AM REALLY HUNGOVER, BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT?
I THINK I WANT TO KEEP IT."
PEOPLE ALWAYS TALK ABOUT HOW
HONEST YOU ARE WHEN YOU'RE
DRUNK.
I HEAR THAT A LOT, "GET THAT GUY
DRUNK AND HE'LLALLY YOU."
WHEN I'M HUNG OVER, THAT'S WHEN
I'M HONEST.
MY LIFE IS IN SHAMBLES I HAVE
NOTHING TO LIVE FOR.
YOUR FRIENDS ARE LIKE, DO YOU
WANT TO GET BRUNCH?
I'M LIKE, I'VE NEVER LIKED YOU.
EVERYTHING IS A LIE WHEN YOU'RE
DRUNK.
YOU'RE LIKE, HEY, IT'S THE BEST
NICE EVER.
THESE ARE MY GOOD FRIENDS AND
SHE'S SUPER HOT AND YOU WAKE UP
AND SAY A WASTE OF TIME, I SPENT
TOO MUCH MONEY, AND THAT'S A
DUDE.
I DRANK A LOT.
I HAVE HORRIBLE ANXIETY, REAL
BAD ANXIETY, RIDDLED WITH
ANXIETY.
BY THE WAY, THE WORD "RIDDLED"
NEVER USED WITH ANYTHING
POSITIVE.
THIS BODY IS RIDDLED WITH CANCER
INSTEAD OF THIS ICE CREAM IS
RIDDLED WITH SPRINKLES.
HORRIBLE ANXIETY.
I LIVE IN THE CITY.
I DON'T HAVE A CAR.
I WALK AROUND EVERYWHERE.
YOU GUYS EVER LEAVE THE HOUSE
WITHOUT HEADPHONES.
WOO!
THOUGHTS ARE NOT GOOD.
MY GOD.
THIS WHOLE TIME I THOUGHT I
LOVED MUSIC.
TURNS OUT I JUST HATE MY BRAIN
BEING ATTACKED ALL DAY LONG BY
THE INSECURITY PLAYLIST ON
SHUFFLE, YOU DRINK TOO MUCH, YOU
ARE GOING TO DIE ALONE.
YOU CALL THAT A PENIS?
YEAH, BECAUSE BEING AN ADULT IS
HARD.
IT'S HARD BEING AN ADULT.
YOU CAN TELL BEING AN ADULT IS
HARD JUST BY THE ABBREVIATIONS.
WHEN YOU'RE A TEENAGER IT'S
L.O.L., O.M.G., B.R.B.
WHEN YOU'RE AN ADULT.
CRAP I HAVE A D.U.I.
I HAVE TO GO TO THE D.M.V..
THE I.R.S. IS UP MY ASS.
I HAVE A U.T.I.
MY I.B.S. IS KICKING IN.
I MIGHT HAVE AN S.T.D.
KIDS ARE LIKE T.M.I.
MAYBE I'M A LITTLE CRANKY.
I GOT CALLED A DOUCHE BAG
RECENTLY.
THAT'S A FUN WORD.
THE INSULT IS MORE POPULAR THAN
THE ACTUAL PRODUCT.
I DON'T KNOW ANYONE WHO HAS EVER
USED A DOUCHE.
NEVER SEEN ONE.
WHAT IS IT LIKE A ZIPLOC?
I FEEL BAD FOR THE GUY WHO
INVENTED THE THING.
I INVENTED THIS THING FOR
WOMEN'S HYGIENES.
WE'LL USE THAT TO DESCRIBE
FEDORAS.
IT'S NOT GOOD FOR YOU, SO
APPARENTLY THE GUY THAT INVENTED
IT, KIND OF A DOUCHE.
( APPLAUSE )
I DON'T KNOW.
I'M NOT THE SWEATING IT.
I DON'T GET TOO OFFENDED BY IT.
I DON'T GET OFFENDED BY MUCH.
MY EX-GIRLFRIEND WAS OFFENDED BY
EVERYTHING.
SHE WAS A REALLY BIG FEMINIST.
I'M A FEMINIST BUT SHE WAS
ANNOYING.
SHE WOULD SAY, "MEN JUST JUDGE
WOMEN BY OUR LOOKS.
WHAT ABOUT OUR ACHIEVEMENTS?
THAT'S TRUE.
MEN THAT.
BUT LADIES, YOU DO THAT, TOO.
WE ALL JUDGE WOMEN.
ONE TIME SHE CALLED ME FLIRT
WEANOTHER GIRL.
SHE WAS LIKE, WHAT, DOES SHE
LOOK LIKE?"
THAT WAS HER FIRST QUESTION.
I WAS LIKE, "WHOA.
WHAT ABOUT HER ACHIEVEMENTS?"
COME ON.
YEAH.
SHE'S ACCOMPLISHED A LOT.
( APPLAUSE )
BUT I GET IT.
IT'S GOT TO BE TOUGH TO BE A
LADY.
I GET IT.
I CAN'T SPEAK FOR IT.
I'M NOT A WOMAN.
I DO THINK WOMEN CAN SAY STUFF
MEN NEVER SAY.
I WAS OUT TO EAT WITH A WOMAN
ONCE AND SHE SAID, "YOU KNOW
WHAT I LIKE IN A GUY, THE STRONG
SILENT TYPE?"
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF A GUY SAID
THAT.
"WHAT DO YOU LOOK FOR IN A
WOMAN?"
"SILENCE.
I LIKE A WOMAN WHO DOESN'T TALK
TOO MUCH."
YOU'D BE KICKED OUT OF SOCIETY.
THAT'S WHY I LIKE OLDER WOMEN.
THEY'VE SEEN IT ALL, BEEN
THROUGH HELL AND BACK.
OLDER WOMEN ARE THE BEST.
I LEARNED ABOUT OLDER WOMEN.
I LEARNED ABOUT MENOPAUSE.
THAT'S FUN.
I'M VERY IGNORANT ABOUT THIS
STUFF.
MY AUNT WENT THROUGH MENOPAUSE.
SHE'S BUMMED OUT AND DEPRESSED.
I THOUGHT THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
MENSTRUATION IS OVER.
IT'S TIME ON MOVE THAT TAMPON
STRING TO THE SIDE.
YOU GRADUATED.
WHY ISN'T THAT A PARTY?
WHERE IS THAT FACEBOOK INVITE?
HEY, AUNT SUSIE STOPPED BLEEDING
EVERY MONTH.
ALL RIGHT!
EVERYBODY IN THE POOL!
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
ALL RIGHT.
NOW YOU SEE WHY I GOT CALLED A
DOUCHE BAG.
THANKS A LOT.
I'M KEVIN.
HAVE A GOOD NIGHT.
>> Stephen: HE'LL BE HEADLINING
THE JOY THEATER IN HIS HOMETOWN
OF NEW ORLEANS ON SEPTEMBER 1.
MARK NORMAND, EVERYBODY!
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.